hello friends of c4 we are truly living
as you all know an unprecedented and
very challenging times right now so I
wanted to connect with you virtually in
this more personal way than just reading
one of my presidents messages and I want
to assure you that we have been
extremely busy over the last few months
engaged I think in both in meaningful
work meaningful research both in terms
of the short term in dealing with the
pandemic and in our long term interest
in using science to address some of the
most important questions facing science
and humanity
I think one of the things one can't help
but notice about this whole pandemic and
how we're gonna approach it and get out
of it is how the centrality of science
not to dealing with the pandemic from
the germ theory disease and physical
distancing to washing our hands to the
Diagnostics to drug development to
vaccine development to the contact
tracing apps that are being developed at
the moment all of this is dependent on
fundamental research and it's
interesting to me that none of it none
of it was developed to deal with koban
19 it was all developed to understand
the world and that's why science and
your support for C far is so important
because that's what we are all about
[Music]